Gabby is with us in Cincinnati hi Gabby
how are you I'm good how are you better
than I deserve what's up so I've been
listening to you for I don't know a
couple months now and we're me and my
husband are in a a little bit of a
situation and he's not really on board
with the whole idea like I mean he's
gone over you know how much weren't that
and everything and we have it written
out and he says he's for it but he's
kind of an impulse buyer and I don't
know he's just not really I know he's
not with it
how old are you I'm I don't know how old
I am I'm 24 and old is he 28 and how
long have you been married four years
okay the issue is I just quit my job
because we had our son in January and I
quit in May and that's basically cut our
income in half which is an issue because
the debt was before that but that's
making a little harder to be like we're
gonna knock this out I guess yeah how
much debt have you got I'm about 78,000
good lord
yeah what does he make you make 65 okay
oh yeah so how much do you owe in your
cars
I'm ten thousand one car okay all right
well I think what you've got to do is
put the kids to bed and sit down with
the candles lit and take his two hands
in your two hands and say hello this is
important to me we need to be grown-ups
with our money this is scaring me bad
and you need to get his attention
you have toddlers and babies hanging all
over you the whole time you're trying to
have conversations you can't have
conversations when they're in bed you
need to get his two eyes locked on your
two eyes and have it very very serious
he needs to hear you
subtlety does not work with men you have
to be very direct with us for us to hear
you and you know yeah you this is a real
difficult situation you get it gotten
yourself into here this is the Dave
Ramsey show